Liberals are learning to love a state
they once smeared as racist Southern
Democrats are pushing for their National
Convention to be held at Atlanta to help
solidify the gains made in Georgia the
last election but I guess they forgot
about the time when they chased out the
MLB All-Star game over a lie about the
state's voting law
this makes Jim Crow look like Jim Eagle
there's High turnout and voter
suppression can take place at the same
time this is Jim Crow on steroids what
they're doing in in Georgia and 40 other
states if they can navigate the
difficulties put in place by Brian Kemp
and Brad gratzenberger to not only game
the system but to suppress voting in the
state of Georgia Jim Crow 2.0 is about
two Insidious things
voter suppression
an election subversion
you should be eating crow Jim Crow
according to a new poll zero percent of
black Georgia voters say they had a poor
voting experience Danny we're just
talking about this I don't know in my
memory of any poll at zero percent I
mean you often like you'll even get like
one percent of the country things were
going in the right direction yes you're
like who are those one percent but I
think this was an incredible result for
the voters of Georgia and I mean all of
them Republicans and Democrats if you
look at Governor Kemp who was under so
much abuse from the Democrats he now has
like a 65 approval rating I think the
highest in the country for any governor
and he just came back from Davos he was
like hey you want to make good vehicles
come to my state because I've got great
workers so he's moved on and the
Democrats cannot move on but also now
they're worried they're like oh boy we
have a state that is sort of turning
perhaps in our Direction because they've
had a lot of people move into the state
there would have had a Stacy Abrams who
got gets a lot of attention and a lot of
fundraising but just cannot seal the
deal even though she said it was stolen
from her the one entity in this that I'm
wondering about is Corporate America did
they learn their lesson because it
wasn't just MLB pulling out but remember
there was like the Coca-Cola thing and
also the Airlines Delta Delta absolutely
and so I you have to wonder if now when
the request comes in from the media like
what is your position Corporation about
X Y or Z woke policy hopefully they
would just decide to take a pass on that
one and let the politics be handled by
somebody else I spoke to somebody today
Republican who lives down in Georgia who
used to work for the former Governor and
he said yes the Democrats are coming to
save us from ourselves we can't wait to
see them yeah you know it seems to me
with the corporations we talked might
have said in the a Blog they were
convinced or coerced by the fear of
activists than they are about their
consumers and that's been a trend
Jessica it must pain you to be part of a
party that is now the party of white
supremacy right because obviously we
were told old over and over again that
Georgia was with this voting bill was
now it's now Jim eagle
um that's been long thrown in my face
and I have to talk about Robert Byrd all
the time I did see the error of his ways
I luckily for the sake of me surviving
this block have been consistent that you
should not say things that they're like
Jim Crow nothing's like the Holocaust
right no one should be compared to a KKK
member unless they're a KKK member these
are things that have happened in history
and no two things are the same right so
you can talk about things that are wrong
right that you when I think it was uh 50
000 people were cleaned off the voter
rolls that's something that you could
talk about that Brian Kemp oversaw are
moving ballot drop boxes things like
that but when you use hyperbole like
that people get stuck in that and then
you get a result like that and you have
egg on your face from that and there are
prominent Democrats like both um
senators from Democratic senators from
Virginia they're pushing really hard for
this Georgia is definitely more purple
but also Republicans ran just uniquely
terrible candidates so their people were
forced essentially to be kept born knock
voters or you know to vote for John off
software if they had had somebody decent
they probably wouldn't have done that so
I understand the push obviously we want
to make as many inroads as possible
um but it's going to be a lot of ads run
like that for sure so uh in summer you
are embarrassed by your party I've
actually changed registration in the
middle of the show that is good that is
good you are now uh you're one of us
judge uh they shamed so many people yeah
and then they're like why would I bet
we're the only show that's pointing out
this this hypocrisy well I don't know if
we are but what I can tell you is this
if they didn't change the election law
that caused Coca-Cola Delta Major League
Baseball to leave so since they haven't
changed the law which they said is
racist and we are racist as a result of
it then liberals decide if a state is
racist based upon whether or not we vote
for them and if we vote for them we're
not racist because there's still that
same racist Jim Pro 2.0 law right but
now Georgia we're going to promote
Georgia because they will because they
voted for Democrats I mean that shows
you the LIE of this racism allegation
and the LIE of you know the voter
suppression and all that I mean Stacy
Abrams didn't win I think her loss was
worse this time so it was I mean the
whole thing is just about the left
destroying people and calling them names
can we create a scenario where the
Democrats are considered racist for this
why would they get why are they doing
it's clearly it's clear that they're
racist
well I mean they fought a civil war to
keep their slaves but call us racist
insurrectionists so they don't care
about the truth they care about the
story because the story can be right it
can be wrong people would rather hear a
story than hear the truth and their
story is and they're sticking to it
Republicans are trying to stop the black
vote even though historically Democrats
I think spent 100 years trying to stop
the black vote
they can go in and have their little
convention there the weather's beautiful
in August you have high 80s no humidity
not a wet time no no I looked it up did
a lot of research on weather in August
there and it's a beautiful time of year
so I'm happy about that what I'm not
happy about is they get all their power
Brokers in Atlanta and they eat and they
drink and they sleep together and they
plot
and then voila
early voting is eons now and all of a
sudden
you plow out all these ballots and all
these ballots get harvested and they
count and they count and they count and
they count until they win
that's what I'm worried about that's a
big worry it's a concern it's going to
be another nail biter yeah yeah and
we're going to go aren't we
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now